right here
this video posted to social media by a
Ukrainian Battalion claims to show their
soldiers crossing the nepro river by
boat into russian-occupied territory in
southern Ukraine in January
an example of the risky Cross River
operations that Ukraine has stepped up
in recent weeks
the nepro river runs through Ukraine
from its northern border through Herson
and into the Black Sea it has served as
the southern front line dividing
Ukrainian and Russian forces for the
last several months
for Ukraine penetrating this part of the
front line is critical for two reasons
first it prevents Russia from sending
troops stationed there to other areas of
the front and second regaining lands
south of the river would disrupt Russian
supply lines and bring Ukrainian troops
to crimea's doorstep
Ukrainian raid teams have been
challenging Russia's control here for
months according to analysts from Janes
and the institute for the study of war
or isw
an analyst from James says that during a
typical raid small boats likely cross
the river a few kilometers from their
desired landing and then ride along the
bank the unit would then disembark from
the boat at least a kilometer from any
Target and infiltrate the rest of the
way on foot
these attacks have increased in recent
weeks
by the beginning of August ukrainians
launched a new effort near the Russian
occupied Village of kozachi Lahiri
video posted on August 9th to telegram
by a Ukrainian reconnaissance team shows
an artillery barrage on the outskirts of
the village possibly the precursor to
one of these raids
another clip posted that same day
appears to show a Russian combat vehicle
Under Fire nearby
isw's mapping of the front lines shows
ukrainians claiming ground west of
kozachi Lahiri on August 11th and 12th
satellite images from August 15th reveal
traces of concentrated shelling around
Russian trenches west of the village
the next day isw's Frontline map shows
Russian forces pushed Ukrainian troops
back across the river
sure
but analysts say these raids have
already created a headache for Moscow
and the threat of more raids in the
future means Russia may need to choose
between risking control of part of its
Southern front
or defending other major hot spots
Russia has lost ground recently in the
zafaresia region fighting continues
around Bak Moot and Russia is attempting
an offensive in the Northeast by
continuing to attack along the nepro
river ukrainians are stretching out
Russian forces and tying up troops here
means it's less likely they can be sent
to these other locations where Russia
needs them
Russia's U.S embassy didn't respond to
requests for comment and Ukrainian
Special Forces declined to comment on
the attacks in kozachi Lahiri
the months ahead defending the southern
front may become an even bigger task for
the Russians
[Music]
north of the now destroyed kokovka Dam
the riverbed is drying up
analysts say this could allow the
Ukrainian Army to send forces across on
foot or in military vehicles putting
even further pressure on Russia's
already thinly stretched forces
[Music]